the idea that you can change your sex by
incantation by saying you know
Abracadabra Stacy
[Laughter]
that's hilarious yeah right like that
that that doesn't sell with the ordinary
person exactly right and when does it
stops kind of like what what's the next
thing because now it's on the gender
situation where if I say I'm a and if
you don't you're you could get canceled
you get you know taken off a YouTube and
you get strikes and it's like it's
insane how it's just that's the like
where's the goal post gun here let's go
into the story let me let's just go into
a few of the stories I want to get into
that right now Korean Jean-Pierre uh uh
said dangerous to say transgender kids
can hurt girls in sports you know when
logic and this is the press secretary
because if she says it you know it's
right so
here's a couple things that's going on
in different states another state just
banned transgender athletes from women's
college sports this is a town hall story
uh Texas governor Albert signed the the
save women's sports act which prohibits
transgender women from participating in
women's college sports Governor Abbott
stated women's sports are being
threatened some women are are being
forced to compete against biological men
Alabama Governor Kay Ivey also signed
legislation Banning male bodied athletes
from competing in women's sports
emphasize fairness if your biological
male you are not going to be competing
in women's and girls Sports in Alabama
Republican state uh representative Susan
Dubose the sponsor of the bill
highlighted the inherent advantage of
being born male no amount of hormone
therapy can undo all those advantages
instances like transgender swimmer Leah
Thomas winning against female athletes
have sparked concerns about fairness and
equal opportunities Tom you got two
girls what are your thoughts when you
see this story here in sports when you
allow that emotional Declaration of who
I feel I am going back to what you're
talking about liberalism is based on
feelings I feel I'm a female now I'm
allowed to go compete and we've seen the
outcome of that a six foot three man
still with male genitalia as was seen by
all the women that were in the locker
room at the Abbey League championships
they said wait a minute they said he was
a girl that there
that's male genitalia hanging off this
guy and number one and number two he's
six three and he had size 13 feet those
are much bigger flippers than the
average the average woman is going to
have picture shocking time exactly if
that picture says a thousand words
take a look at the cowboy hat in her
expression be glad she's not armed
ladies and gentlemen because that's an
angry cowgirl there yeah so the first
thing is you have to take out of this
there's no time there's no validation
there's no test it's an emotional thing
and so you need to protect them this is
swimming showed the performance now the
risk was showed up in October of 2022 in
Cherokee County in North Carolina where
the volleyball Spike knocked the girl
unconscious and she was having
concussion systems symptoms for three
weeks CAT scans proved it and then what
used to be a fairly liberal School Board
they voted 5-1 and said yeah after we
saw that volleyball Spike maybe you
can't declare a Monday you're a female
Common Sense prevails Common Sense
Prevail because they saw what happened
there well and have you played this clip
go ahead and play the clip see whatever
you got a concussion here watch watch
this lower right they should highlight
girl
watch this here she comes that's that's
a guy that's a male jumping boom she's
out she's done that's it
and so the school board saw this and
goes how long is the girl over there
nine weeks apparently she declared she
was female nine weeks and she's playing
and that's what Leah Thomas said I want
to win a championship so I declare it
I've probably into more trans people
than than most people a lot of trans
people are also being thrown under this
bus because this is being done not on
their behalf this is being done by like
activists a lot of trans people are
actually quite sensible they're like
look I'm not comfortable in my body I
want to live in a different way I don't
need you to pretend that I am literally
the opposite sex just just don't beat me
up and leave me alone exactly right and
I kind of feel sorry for them but I'll
make another I'll tell you a story that
will blow your mind which is kind of
relevant to this so my grandmother was
born in a gulag wow she was born in a
concentration camp
for political prisoners and one of the
things people don't know is once you're
released from these camps you would be
you would not be allowed to live within
like a hundred miles of any big city so
you'd have to live in some kind of
remote town and they all ended up
settling in these remote towns in the
middle of Siberia and the only people
that lived there were the former
prisoners of the camps a few of the
local native tribes of which there were
many and the guards from the very same
camps that the prisoners came to came
from and they would live in the same
building my grandmother's family they
lived in a landing across from another
apartment and another apartment there
was a guy who was a God okay and what
she told me is when Stalin died right
and he was exposed as having committed
all these terrible atrocities and so on
there was a Spate of suicides in this
town because these guards they all
killed themselves because they genuinely
believed they were doing the right thing
when they were beating these people and
torturing these people and that's one
you know hearing those stories from my
family that's when I really learned from
early days to get people to do something
terrible but think they're good you need
ideology and this is ideology this isn't
real this isn't Common Sense this isn't
people thinking about it critically this
is ideology and that's how you get to
the point where you've got massive guys
playing against little girls that's how
you get there because it's ideology
people aren't actually examining the
facts and and trying to get to the right
place they're going to news that
argument is going to remember remember
how how confident these people when they
were saying defund the police defund the
police defund the police do you remember
those guys oh yeah and now they're like
we never said that yeah yeah right we
never said that and then their house
quickly